good to see you guys nice to see you
guys thanks for having us
um chris you do so much on this show
like obviously behind the scenes too but
on screen we're seeing you do so many
things is there a particular sequence or
episode that you're really excited for
people to watch
wow uh
gosh there's so many sequences i mean
it's really it's eight hours of of
programming and so
each each hour is almost its own
thematic
genre in a way i mean it's psychological
thriller that turns to revenge thriller
that turns to conspiracy thriller um i'm
really eager for people to see all of
the authentic uh navy seal sort of
weapons handling that's that's something
i'm really excited for people to see um
i'm really excited for people to
to see um
the various psychological thriller
elements of the first like third of the
series it feels a little like jacob's
ladder or memento or hitchcock in a way
so i think that's exciting something
i've never done before and people maybe
have never seen me do before and then
there's just really great action
sequences uh really great moments of
of revenge and redemption and and uh i
mean it's it's hard to pick one thing
i'm really proud of it
both of you guys have done projects
previously where you've gotten military
training to play you know military man
taylor i'm wondering how much of that
past
uh training applies whenever you do
another project similar in a similar
vein i mean we're spoiled to be
surrounded by these guys and the guy who
ray mendoza who trained me for lone
survivor
i was talking about coming on board and
ray texted me he was already
a military advisor on this on terminal
list
and so that was actually a factor of me
coming in having that trust with ray and
knowing it's going to be the best and
reach these action sequences are going
to reach their potential
um and to reconnect with ray who who's
honestly like a brother to me since lone
was was awesome and
i mean one of his best friends was on
set you know produced yeah i mean we
were surrounded by the best yeah we
really it was really important for us to
maintain that level of authenticity and
to honor the community for which uh we
both have such an affinity and these and
these special operators and these men
who have
you know really been forged in the
crucible of war
and who who
you know have come out on the other side
and are now in in the movie-making
business and so they're working as tech
advisors writers producers actors and
and we surrounded ourselves with them so
that any inauthenticity that we might
not be able to pick up is just two guys
who have played seals but aren't seals
they would pick up and say no you got to
do that again and we always honor them
and let them uh let them watch the
footage and make sure that we were
dotting every eye and crossing every tee
awesome guys well you've done a
phenomenal thing with this series quite
an accomplishment congrats good talking
to you thank you nice to talk to you
thank you